this video was made possible by
curiosity stream and nebula there's
another full-length companion video all
about anti-slap laws which you can
access by signing up for the curiosity
stream nebula bundle for less than 15 a
year at the link below
kyle rittenhouse is out for blood
no not that kind he's out to get revenge
on anyone that called him a murder and
he has specifically named whoopi
goldberg sank wieger lebron james and
joe biden now unless you've been living
under a rock for the past couple of
years then you probably know who kyle
ridden house is but for those who need a
brief refresher in 2021 a jury acquitted
written house for homicide attempted
homicide and reckless endangerment in
connection with the deaths of joseph
rosenbaum anthony huber and the wounding
of gage grouskroyds rittenhouse shot
these individuals during the unrest
surrounding the 2020 racial justice
protests in kenosha wisconsin the jury
likely concluded that riddenhaus had
acted in self-defense and therefore was
not criminally liable for the shootings
now the reactions to the verdict in the
case itself were predictably polarizing
along partisan lines many americans on
the political right notably gun rights
groups and far-right members of congress
celebrated britain house as a folk hero
painting him as a crusader for justice
who had stood up against a raging mob
kyle rittenhouse is not guilty my
friends you have a right to defend
yourself riddenhaus even took a
months-long victory lap in maga country
meeting with donald trump at mar-a-lago
giving interviews to tucker carlson in
contrast many americans on the political
left viewed the verdict as a
jury-sanctioned endorsement of armed
vigilante justice rittenhouse's critics
have routinely savaged him as a murderer
white supremacist and even a domestic
terrorist a 17 year old vigilante
arguably a domestic terrorist picked up
a rifle drove to a different state to
shoot people and since his acquittal
written house has declared his intention
to strike back against his critics
through the power of the almighty
lawsuit in a february 2022 interview
with tucker carlson rittenhouse
announced the creation of the media
accountability project which written
house described as quote a tool to help
fundraise and hold the media accountable
for the lies they said and deal with
them in court ridden house told carlson
that he planned to bring defamation
lawsuits against anyone who called him a
white supremacist or a murderer
specifically naming the views whoopi
goldberg and the host of the young turks
program sank uighur for characterizing
his killings as murder even after his
acquittal ridden houses also said he
plans to sue lebron james for suggesting
his tears during the trial were fake and
joe biden for his campaign tweeting out
a video linking written house to white
supremacy in 2020 so today legal eagles
let's think like a defamation lawyer and
attempt to answer the 64 million dollar
legal question what is kyle
rittenhouse's likelihood of prevailing
on the merits of this threatened
litigation
[Music]
now first let's talk about the basics of
defamation law what does it mean to
defame someone well simply put
defamation is a tort to create civil
liability for the publication of a false
statement but a third party that
unjustly injures another's reputation
now there's no federal defamation
statute and states may define defamation
in slightly different ways but to prove
defamation generally a plaintiff must
typically establish four basic elements
of their claim first a plaintiff has to
make a false statement a verifiable fact
a verifiable fact is assertion that is
capable of being definitively proven
true or false in contrast statements of
opinion that cannot be understood by a
reasonable listener to be literal
assertions of fact are not defamatory
though simply labeling a statement as
your opinion doesn't make it so either
you said that in your opinion kindling
is the best wood to start a fire well
isn't it hank of course it is but it's
not your opinion it's a known fact now
second the false statement has to be
made to a third person this
communication or publication can be
either verbal or written but it has to
be to someone other than the subject of
the defamation now third the party
publishing the false statement has to
have some fault in disseminating the
defamatory communication this amount of
fault one needs to show depends on
whether the defamed individual is a
private figure or public figure a
private figure claiming defamation such
as a neighbor a store clerk or a barista
only has to show negligent publication
meaning that a reasonable person would
not have published the defamatory
statement or a reasonable person would
have known that it was false now a
public figure like a celebrity or a
member of congress or a presidential
candidate
has to prove actual mouse meaning that
the defendant made a statement either
knowing that it was false or
acting in reckless disregard for the
truth now the standard also applies to a
limited purpose public figure who is one
who voluntarily participates in a
discussion about a public controversy
and has access to the media to get his
or her views across now under the
standard written house probably
qualifies as a limited purpose public
figure which means that only specific
false factual assertions harmful to his
reputation that were known to be untrue
or were made in reckless disregard of
the truth would give rise to defamation
in this case in other words written
house is subject to the higher standard
and then finally the fourth element of
defamation is the subject of the
statement has to have suffered some kind
of quantifiable damages now at the same
time there is something called
defamation per se now a lot of people
get this wrong defamation per se means
that if you have made a defamatory
statement in one of these categories
damages are presumed for liability it
doesn't mean defamation is automatic it
just means you don't have to show
damages right off the bat that happens
when you claim that someone is involved
in criminal activity has a loathsome
contagious or infectious disease was
unchased or engaged in sexual misconduct
or has engaged in conduct incompatible
with the proper conduct of one's
business or profession now this came
about in the cardi b affair where
someone claimed that cardi b had an sti
now that qualified as defamation per se
but
again you still have to prove defamation
it just means you can skip damages uh
for the first time around so with that
understanding let's look to the
potential targets of litigation from
written house and we start with the king
himself lebron james now when ridden
house took to the stand in his own
defense he famously got emotional and
broke down in tears during his testimony
lebron questioned the tears and
suggested that he had some lemon heads
before taking the stand now it's not
clear that there are any other allegedly
defamatory statements that written house
would rely upon for a potential action
against the ball player turned space jam
to star but this tweet was the only
publication that had been cited in news
reports for kyle's hypothetical
defamation suit so if ridden house
attended to sue based on this tweet
alone
he would surely fail on the grounds that
this is james's opinion and not a
defamatory fact written house would have
to show that james was making an
assertion of verifiable fact capable of
being proven true or false but internal
thoughts or feelings by their very
nature cannot be proven true or false no
matter how much another insists that
they are being sincere and here we all
saw the footage and here it's just
lebron opining based on the
facts that everyone else could see and
just as the wire's omar little had a
saying if kyle decides to take on king
james based on this single tweet well
he's probably going to miss pretty badly
you come at the k
you best not miss
but next can written how sue joe biden
and others for defamation for suggesting
that he's a white supremacist or
domestic terrorist now some conservative
attorneys and commentators have called
for written house to bring defamation
actions against anyone
from tv pundits to president joe biden
for purportedly linking him to white
supremacists for example msnbc's tiffany
cross referred to written house after
the verdict as quote this little
murderous white supremacist journalist
john heilemann appeared on msnbc
described britain house as quote
arguably a domestic terrorist and during
the 2020 campaign joe biden's twitter
account shared a video condemning donald
trump for failing to denounce white
supremacy and other far-right groups
which included footage of rittenhouse so
herein lies the question does written
house have a defamation cause of action
for being called a white supremacist or
domestic terrorist answer probably not
well for starters courts have repeatedly
held broad labels that describe
someone's beliefs like racist or white
supremacist or even terrorist are
generally non-defamatory opinions for
example in brimelow versus the new york
times company a federal judge held that
the new york times article describing a
prominent opponent of non-white
immigration as quote a white nationalist
white supremacist and anti-semitic were
non-actionable opinions the lawsuit was
dismissed and the dismissal was affirmed
on appeal furthermore the u.s supreme
court has highlighted that the right to
use hyperbolic language and make
figurative exaggerations are necessary
for spirited public debate for example
in the case milkovich versus the
lorraine journal the supreme court said
quote the constitution protects
statements that cannot reasonably be
interpreted as stating actual facts
about an individual made in debate over
public matters in order to provide
assurance that public debate will not
suffer for lack of imaginative
expression or the rhetorical hyperbole
which has traditionally added much to
the discourse of our nation now
milkovitch in subsequent cases have held
rhetorical hyperbole can be a valid
defense to defamation if the statements
are found to constitute opinions and
statements that are full of exaggeration
and innuendo or are just asking
questions are more likely to be deemed
hyperbolic opinions rather than
statements of unambiguous fact and in
2020 a judge dismissed a defamation
claim against rachel maddow on the
grounds that she had engaged in
rhetorical hyperbole the lawsuit was
brought after matto told viewers of her
show that the conservative news network
oann quote really literally is paid
russian propaganda the court agreed that
while maddow did exaggerate the facts by
calling oann russian propaganda her
statement in context was found to be
quote consistent with her tone up to
that point and a reasonable viewer would
not take the statement as factual given
the context the context of maddow's
statement shows reasonable viewers would
consider the contested statement to be
her opinion and in support of this
conclusion the court noted that
merriam-webster's own definition of the
word literally now includes a secondary
defamation to mean quote in effect
virtually used in an exaggerated way to
emphasize a statement or description
that is not literally true or possible
now legally the court came to the
correct decision now linguistically
i just
i can't i refuse to accept that
literally now means figuratively just
because everyone misused the word enough
that the dictionary said fine whatever
literally now means not literally now
and they use the word literally to
contradict the term it's it's it's
insane i literally want to rip your head
off you mean figuratively no i literally
mean
literally that being said
it was still rhetorical hyperbole and
the same probably goes for the white
supremacist label as well in part
because of written house's own willing
association with the far-right proud
boys which invited people to make
reasonable commentary on his personal
views for example in january 2021
written house was photographed and
recorded in a mount pleasant bar being
serenaded by members of the proud boys a
self-described quote western chauvinist
group whom the fbi labeled in 2018 as an
extremist group with white nationalist
ties at the bar rittenhouse posed for
photos holding up the okay hand gesture
with the proud boy members that hand
gesture has been co-opted by white
supremacists maybe ironically maybe not
ironically it depends on who you ask but
rittenhouse and his lawyers have long
argued that written house does not
belong to any far-right groups and is
not racist britain house's lawyers
successfully excluded evidence from the
jury that any purported ties to the
proud boys and rittenhouse even told
tucker carlson after his acquittal that
he supports black lives matter and as
one pundit put it quote the perception
that written house is a racist may be
incorrect but it's not unreasonable if
someone had published an article saying
kyle rittenhouse is a member of a white
supremacist organization that is a
statement of fact and can be proven true
or untrue but if an article said he
posed with the proud boys and flashed a
white supremacist sign and as a white
supremacist that may be an incorrect
conclusion but it's a reasonable one it
may also qualify as an opinion and on
top of that since kyle rittenhouse is
probably a public figure at this point
unless rittenhouse can point to specific
news reports claiming he definitively
belongs to a white supremacist group or
group that calls for engaging in
domestic terrorism as opposed to
speculation that he personally holds
such views it's unlikely that written
house will succeed to sue anyone for
calling him a racist a white supremacist
or domestic terrorist whether you're
talking about
rachel maddow or joe biden it's probably
not going to work but then there's the
question of can written how sue the
mainstream media or politicians for
calling him a murderer now this was
going on a lot and the issue of whether
written house could sue pundits or
politicians for calling him a murderer
is probably closer than the prior two
questions
shortly after written house was
acquitted in november of 2021 whoopi
goldberg for example said on the view
that she still believed he was guilty
even all the excuses in the world
does not change the fact that three
people got shot to me it's murder i'm
sorry and britton house told tucker
carlson that people like whoopi goldberg
defamed him by calling him a murderer
even after being acquitted so the
question is is he right well to give
everyone's favorite answer it depends
but probably not now legally speaking
the jury found written house not guilty
and the only thing that you can surmise
as a result of that verdict is that the
prosecution didn't meet its burden that
there might have been reasonable doubts
the jury might also have believed that
britain house acted in self-defense but
you can't necessarily know exactly what
they meant from the fact that they found
him not guilty it isn't necessarily a
repudiation of the idea that he
committed murder though if i was
representing written house i would
probably point it as very strong
evidence that he did not in fact commit
murder especially under these
circumstances and the statement that
someone is a murderer or committed
murder could be a little bit more dicey
and as explained by first amendment
scholar and my former law professor
eugene volk if a statement that written
house is a murderer implies the speaker
knows undisclosed or unpublicized facts
that could implicate him that could
potentially be defamatory for example if
a pundit stated quote i had a
conversation with rittenhouse yesterday
and he told me a lot about what happened
the man is a murderer that could be an
actionable factual assertion in contrast
if the statement merely expresses the
speaker's opinion based on the public
facts that have been discussed and
publicly disclosed that's probably not
actionable so if a pundit were to say
i've watched a lot of coverage of the
case and the jury got it wrong the man
is a murderer that is likely a
non-actionable opinion so generally
speaking when people referred to ridden
house as a murderer it probably wouldn't
have been defamatory because people
wouldn't have any reason to believe that
the speakers had inside knowledge beyond
what had been reported in the news and
of course there was lots and lots of
news coverage now a similar case
happened when radio host bob lonsberry
referred to john giselle who had been
acquitted of negligent homicide after
shooting a man to death in a hunting
accident as a cold-blooded murderer on
air and asserting that the fatal
shooting quote could not have been an
accident the court reasoned that
lonsbury's statements were based on
facts widely reported by the media and
could not reasonably be interpreted by
listeners as being based on undisclosed
information and furthermore these
statements were in the words of the
court quote obviously intended to be
confrontational rather than factual and
thus there was non-actionable expression
of pure opinion and of course it goes
both ways tucker carlson accused a
public figure of a crime and was rescued
from defamation thanks to his own
rhetorical hyperbole as you may know in
2020 model and actress karen mcdougall
who allegedly was paid 150 thousand
dollars to keep quiet about an affair
with donald trump sued fox news for
defamation after carlson accused her on
his program of engaging in quote a
classic case of extortion against donald
trump and in getting the case dismissed
fox news successfully argued the general
tenor of tucker carlson's show puts
viewers on notice that his statements
should not be taken literally
quote tucker carlson is not stating
actual facts about the topics he
discusses and is instead engaging in
quote exaggeration and non-literal
commentary fox persuasively argues that
given mr carlson's reputation any
reasonable viewer arrives with an
appropriate amount of skepticism about
the statements he makes whether the
court frames mr carlson's statements as
exaggeration non-literal commentary or
simply bloviating for his audience the
conclusion remains the same the
statements are not actionable now
whether any of written house's claims
hold water is sort of irrelevant to the
question of whether he can sue someone
in america you can sue anyone at any
time for anything
it just means you might not be
successful there at the end if it were
to go to trial it's entirely possible
that he might file suit and that some
people might settle potentially for
nuisance value just to make it go away
this is probably what happened in the
nicholas sandman case but the bottom
line is that written houses lawsuits
legally speaking almost certainly are
going to fail now what if i told you you
could watch another legal eagle video
but this time it's on whether
rittenhouse could be countersued under
anti-slap laws if he actually did file
any of these defamation suits well this
full-length companion video exists and
is exclusively on nebula because sadly
if i put it on youtube it would probably
get demonetized and there's no way you'd
ever see it but nebula is different as
you've probably heard by now nebula is
home to tons of exclusive ad-free
content like my first full-length
documentary bad law words good my
extended interview with mark rober and
another exclusive video legal rights
that you definitely want to use and tons
tons more all of this exclusive content
is only on nebula which you can get for
free with curiosity stream of course the
reason why all these videos are only
available on nebula is because they just
wouldn't work on youtube and they'd
probably never be viewed because of the
way that the site works nebula is a
platform for great and unique content
that's made by independent educational
creators ones you probably already know
like tom scott thomas frank and thomas
flight as well as a whole bunch of other
people not named tom like half is
interesting mkbhd real life lore
wendover productions mike boyd minute
earth neo and real engineering and so
many others there's new exclusive
content released every single day and
nebula is creator owned and creator
operated and by the way we've been
developing nebula like crazy so there's
now an ios app android apple tv roku
fire tv and android tv apps my fellow
creators and i really care about nebula
and we're thrilled to be partnering with
curiositystream because they're the
go-to source for the best documentaries
and long-form educational content on the
internet they even have an entire
section devoted to unsolved mysteries
and crime so if you like my videos
you'll love the stuff on curiosity
stream and the best way to access nebula
and all of the other incredible content
is through the amazing curiosity stream
nebula bundle deal with its current
sales price of less than 15 a year where
you get access to both and to be clear
that nebulous subscription isn't a trial
it's free for as long as you're a
curiosity stream member i genuinely
don't know a better deal that exists
anywhere on the internet where you get
two great streaming sites with content
that you'll actually enjoy and watch for
less than 15 per year at the current
sales price but what's more signing up
will actually help countless independent
educational creators beyond just legal
eagle so please make sure to do so by
clicking on the link that's on screen
right now which will take you directly
to
curiositystream.com legaleagle to sign
up for both curiosity stream and nebula
for less than 15 for the entire year or
you can click on the link that's down
below in the description it's a great
way to support educational content and
get tons of exclusive content that
you'll actually want to watch
or you can click on this playlist over
here with my other real law reviews so
click on this playlist or this link or
i'll see you in court